Democratic congresswoman Maxine Waters
at it again renewing her call to impeach
President Trump only now she says it's
keeping her up at night I wake up in the
middle of the night and all I can think
about is I'm gonna get him I'm not gonna
move and as you know there's a
difference and how some of our
leadership talked about how we should
handle all of this they say Maxine
please don't say impeachment anymore and
when they say that I say impeach me you
may remember waters back in June earning
supporters to harass Trump officials out
in public
she's now defending those remarks in a
way only Maxine Waters can I did not
threaten his constituents his supporters
I do that all the time but I didn't do
at that time what bothered me so much
was they tried to frame that as violence
that's not violence as a matter of fact
I said the poster child for violence is
the President of the United States okay
one you were laughing about that what
was so funny what when I hear it
Maxine Waters talk like this I think oh
gee I wonder who started the bullying
the instability the harshness and she's
right I mean he's the one that said I
remember the good old days when they
would knock a protester out or I'll pay
your legal bills after you slug a guy I
mean the DNC paid protests oh please
here we go I'm just saying
or you never want to talk about Trump do
everything it's the mean you just don't
like to talk about Trump and his
excesses
okay so Maxine Waters done that she's so
great that she can run around and say
you know what I can threaten his
followers he's got to be impeached now
she says vice president Pence needs to
be impeached who is this woman is she a
comedian at least she's smart unlike
some who call her
like some people who want to call her
that I think obviously she is having an
impact cuz even Nancy Pelosi and others
I know that you don't like Nancy but
Nancy Pelosi said don't do it she said
don't say impeach don't you know and she
she is having success doing her own well
that's the game though because the game
I think Pelosi is running is you don't
want to say impeachment until we win
back the house right so when maximum
water says she wakes up in the middle of
the night and she's awake up in the
middle of the night is like Jasper would
you please move over I'm going to go
after any politician Evers never
happened in my life but Pelosi is saying
is don't say it out loud because what
happened to Bill Clinton when he was
president when the Republicans caved to
the base really and said okay we are
going to start impeachment hearings
before the midterms well guess what
Democrats United right behind all of
them got behind Bill Clinton his
popularity went up he was able to
succeed and he walked out of the White
House in much better shape than if they
had just held their fire yeah Maxine's
firing up the Republicans well it's
funny I also scream impeachment him in
the middle of the night because it's my
safe word you got it you have to
understand that like okay ten years ago
her opinions would be seen as extreme or
radical but now she's the mainstream of
the Democratic Party and the reason is
is that Trump has been good for her and
her constituents first her constituents
are enjoying record low unemployment and
a booming economy and they're not dying
in foreign wars
that's pretty good I mean he's died
being the second but also as her profile
has never been higher now what she's act
now what she speaks people listen he's
good for business her business as well
she fires up both bases she fires up her
base and their bases that's why I think
they should go head to head
don't unseat him try to beat him run for
out run for president yeah maxime should
run what the point that you make is so
good and that is who ever heard of this
woman until she started yelling impeach
impeach impeach 45 honestly had you
heard of her oh yeah I've known AK scene
forever because she's so very
entertaining know her oh how do I know
her she's what she's a leading voice
would impeach what is her message other
than go after people get in their face
make a crowd who talks like that
Donald mirror image of Locker upright
[Applause]
crimes I mean there's no question about
that had they had a real grand jury then
that would have been something that
would have happened yeah well they did
one is winning a high crime and
misdemeanor last time I checked winnings
not grounds for impeachment no not
unless you cheat and bully and lie but
that's still yo you could still another
way you could she listened Maxine is at
it again
and it's okay because she has denied now
that she wants to cause violence to
people but if you read the quote create
a crowd push back tell them they're not
welcome right but you need that's gonna
cause great thing about her is she is
guaranteed at least one second she's
guaranteed us one segment a week she
will do something and we get one second
Hillary yeah it used to be Hillary
talking Maxine we love you